riley a l'air de faire super la tête
mais pourquoi il fait super est égale
tête tu veux qu'elle fasse toute saisine
torture bijoux à se réfère ce qu'il faut
mais oui c'est ça jusqu'à ce qu'elles
reviennent on a qu'a fait quelle forêt
pour la bonne idée colère peur des goûts
tu trouves avant tout respire la joie de
vivre
j'ai une grande nouvelle j'ai trouvé un
club de hockey junior ici à san
francisco et écoute ça les sélections
auront lieu demain après l'école
quelle chance ragon oui ok ce convoi
d'accord avec toi t'as qu'à me faire
passer pour voir la parade de refaire du
patin à glace aussi ce serait génial
mais si t'es quoi ça c'était pas joyeux
du tout venant parce que la joie je sais
pas faire mais j'avais pas remarqué
vous avez vu ce que j'ai vu c'est du
vent et oui de l'huile prend faucon la
cuisine enquête tout mais en douceur
qu'elle ne remarque que rien alors
comment s'est passé ce premier jour
d'école attention elles nos cuisines se
passe mon tour va-t-il c'est ok
villageois d'accord bien
enfin je crois je sais pas trop au
magnifique ça c'était vraiment trop la
joie